it's up to you whether you take offense
it's up to you whether someone an
anonymous frog person online can write
you're a bad dude and then next thing
you know you're about to jump off the
roof of the building uh Alyssa Milano
though she's a Hollywood actress they're
not noted for you know strong sort of
moral or psychological conviction she
had to go to therapy because of Twitter
right but do yourself I know it is about
self-care yeah it is
for one thing you've never ever read the
comments I always read the comments who
doesn't read the comments the comments
when we each joined the show do you turn
the comments off no I just don't read
them I'm not interested unless it's
somebody that I respect yeah well I have
another question I left uh she left yeah
I can't take it anymore I respect that
listen I've spent many many days with my
therapist talking about about what
Anonymous person said to you yeah right
yeah people know you somebody who
doesn't know you hasn't yet you doesn't
know your family doesn't know you
doesn't know anything about you yeah but
we let them all right the given the
devil is due portion of this yes there
are mean Anonymous people there out
there and I can be completely dismissive
of it but yes sometimes they can say
something that really upsets you I find
when people are just like ah you're a
mean words like I don't care about that
I don't like when they selectively edit
what I say that's something that bothers
me by me saying it just now I probably
instigated even more of it but it's just
it's just the nature of all of this and
before social media people used to say
mean things about people people when I
was a kid people used to write mean
things about people in the bathroom
stall that's you know that's what they
used to do you guys don't even know
about that young kids in here well you
go to clean bathrooms you don't know
what it was you I grew up it was New
York that's what people do mean things
um
people do say mean things I think
there's sort of a funny part of this how
joy and whoopee are like no we never
look at the comments Joy only wants to
hear from people she respects I don't
know how you'd be able to do that on
Twitter only get responses from people
you respect uh you know my personal
policy on this is this is why I started
locals locals the locals guys watching
right now and that are in the chat I
read the comments every day I respond to
as many as I can every day uh I have
because I wanted to build a community
the Twitter is a town square and if you
were walking into the Town Square
picture old school we're back in the day
let's go back 100 years right little
towns All Over America that are starting
and then in the Town Square that's where
people would congregate that's where you
know the the main stores were that's
where everybody would go for Commerce
for to eat to get food Etc and then
they'd start talking and exchanging
ideas and there might have even been a
guy on a soapbox there and he'd be
complaining about this or that but you
did not have to talk to everybody you
did not have to turn to everybody who
commented on something and if there was
a crazy person over there you might walk
the other way so I what I did with
locals was built something that was my
own personal community and it's a
beautiful thing Twitter I scan through
the comments but I'm not looking to just
fight with people all day or anything
else it's like lady grow up grow up